on Monday the US defense secretary held
talks in Tel Aviv speaking alongside his
Israeli counterparts Lloyd Austin said
Washington would not dictate Israel's
war but the death toll is soaring and he
says he's urg Israeli leaders to do more
to protect civilians in Gaza L Austin
also announced the launch of a naval
task force to respond to ongoing attacks
by Yemen's houthis and Commercial
vessels in the Red Sea the oil giant BP
is the latest company to Halt shipments
through those Waters
these attacks are
Reckless dangerous and they violate
international law and so we're taking
action to uh build an International
Coalition to address this threat and I
would remind you that this is not just a
US
issue uh this is this is an
international problem and it deserves an
international uh response uh and that's
why uh I'm convening a meeting
tomorrow uh a ministerial meeting with
fellow ministers in a region and Beyond
uh to uh to address this threat the
right SE is one of the world's most
important shipping lanes Marco foron is
director General at The Institute of
export and international trade and he
says the latest disruption to shipping
could have a significant impact on the
global
economy the reality is that we are only
at the beginning of what could be a a
long period of uncertainty and
instability as you've already
highlighted the entry to the uh Red Sea
the bab Al mandab Straits are a key
transit route uh for about 10% of global
container oil 8% of the world's uh LPG
uh goes through and about 30% of the
world's container shipping goes through
those Straits uh either on the way to or
from Suez so the implications of
constraints and delays here are really
significant for the GL global economy
Alan what more do we know about this
Naval Coalition that the US defense
secretary has been talking
about well if you take a look at the the
list of countries that are openly
involved in that then there is only one
Arab country which is Bahrain now they
talk about how some will be involved in
intelligence gathering others will be
involved in the Red Sea and the
intention is of course that it will the
terror attacks uh from the houthis but
we've heard from a number of companies
have already decided to stop their
operations through the Red Sea this may
give them a degree of security a degree
of hope that they'll be safe that they
won't be attacked by the huies but it's
going to take some time to build that
confidence up so clearly this is an
operation that has been in the planning
for some considerable time they believe
they're acting on it now and bringing
countries together to show it's an
international effort not just supporting
Israel but supporting many many other
countries who use the Red Sea as the
main
conduit going avoiding the Red Sea adds
about 3 weeks to every ship's Journey
from Asia to Europe so the Americans are
hoping that this will act to some level
of security for companies who use that
shipping Lane Alan Fischer in occupied
East Jerusalem Alan thank you